hello absolutely i'm sure there is you
know there it's much bigger job leading
a large corporation and there's some
aspects of luck that determine who rises
to the top in large corporations but you
know they're all they're all important
skills and when you meet powerful
business leaders well the one thing you
do understand very clearly is that there
is something about them that led them to
rise to the top that that there there
are these definable characteristics of
strong leaders well there are you know a
sense of a sense of assurance about what
what you're doing a sense of vision
about what your role in society is and
you know the ability to articulate that
vision so certainly self-confidence and
some strong sense of values
you